-Did you stay up
late last night?
Did you watch election returns?
-I did. I did. I did.
-How do you feel?
-I feel...
I don't know.
How do you --
I mean, maybe I would say
I would like to use you
as a sort of yardstick,
a sort of -- my gold standard
for how I should feel,
emotionally,
like, my level of rationality,
post-midterm,
post-cable exposure.
-Yes.
-You know, projection.
-It was a hard -- I forgot how
stressful projections are.
-Oh, God, I just wish they would
stop that part, in a way.
-Yeah. I wish it was more --
at the very --
They wouldn't say anything
about results,
and at the end of the night,
they would just go,
"This happened," and you would
just go, "Okay, great."
-And let it just be, like,
on a slow scroll
or just let it sort of
rise to the surface.
Like, maybe it sort of
appears and then it dissolves.
-Yeah.
-But I feel as if --
And I feel as if
two things were happening
last night.
I feel like one place was
trying to be extremely calm...
-Yes.
-...if you know what
I'm talking about.
-Uh-huh.
-One outlet.
And then I feel like another
outlet was really lively,
and it felt like maybe, like,
the common space in a dorm.
-Right. Everybody just
kind of -- Yeah.
-You know -- But I don't know.
How do you feel?
I don't know.
-The only thing I found very
stressful last night
is how every time
something happened,
they'd go,
"We have a big result."
And you realize they never say,
"This next one is meaningless."
-Yeah.
-"We have a meaningless result
from a state
that doesn't matter."
Yeah, but, you know, I don't
quite know how to feel either.
I mean, I certainly know
I could feel worse.
-Right, right.
I've said that to myself.
-And I didn't feel that
two years ago.
-Yes. No, no.
-You know what I mean?
Two years ago, I didn't say,
"Well, it could
have been worse."
-Yeah. No. Exactly.
And then, in fact,
it proved to be worse.
-Right.
But on the night,
I couldn't imagine.
-You thought, well, yes,
there is some comfort
in knowing --
-With that, yeah, so --
But I'm also trepidatious about
what it means -- I mean,
I don't -- based on even
the events of today,
I don't feel like,
"Well, we had a midterm, and
then everything settled down."
-Right.
Now, this is a question
that I did.
I asked so many -- Mostly, I
asked the television last night,
but some people
around me did say,
"That's a good question."
When people were --
I wouldn't say gloating,
but there was, you know,
some people
felt really positive
about this blue wave.
Let's call it a wave.
And they were saying, you know,
this is an opportunity
for the Democrats,
you know, to do, A, B, C.
And I kept screaming,
"But what in the next --"
There's two more months.
I mean, what if he,
for instance,
should fire or ask
the Attorney General
to, you know --
-"You should resign."
Yeah.
I think we'd be
better off apart."
-Yeah, exactly.
What about
the remaining two months?
It's an opportunity.
It's a recipe for
all sorts of -- you know?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And nobody -- Well,
no one on the television
would answer me,
because they couldn't hear me.
-Yeah. And that's really one of
the downsides
of television, right?
Yeah. I mean, everybody
says we're living in
the golden age of television,
and you're like,
"Well, then how come
they won't talk to me?"
-I know.
I had --
A long time ago, somebody --
I was telling a story about --
I was like, "Oh, my friend --
he told me this really,
you know, amusing story."
And I went ahead
and I told the story.
And then they asked, "You know,
which friend was that?"
And I was like, "I think it was
Johnny Carson told --
Johnny Carson told all of
America this story last night."
But he was my friend.
-Yeah.
Yeah, that's totally normal,
and you shouldn't feel weird.
I mentioned the
golden age of television.
I want to tell you this, because
everybody says, right now,
there's so many good shows,
and it's so hard to figure out
what to watch.
My wife and I are watching
"Sex and the City."
We're watching
two episodes a night.
I have never watched it.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Wow! two episodes a night.
-This was a request
my wife made and said,
"Hey, this is a show
I've watched a hundred times,
and I feel like you would
understand me better
if you watched this show."
And I want to say,
I'm enjoying it so much,
and it is a show that I
underestimated, having not seen,
just based on --
-Did somebody say, "Wow"?
-But I didn't --
But I will admit,
and, obviously, I cost myself.
Unfortunately, I'm getting this
great experience now.
But have you found
that's happened before,
where people have said
to you like,
"Oh, I thought,
even just based on
the color palette
of the show --"
-Well, first of all, yes.
I want to say that I think
it's very big of you
to share not just with me
but with all of America
that you feel that
your life is --
-It's enriched.
-Enriched.
-Yes.
-That's what I was gonna say.
And I will say
it's really lovely to hear,
because I think there was --
There's always been
a slight --
You know, I do feel that the
show suffered a wee bit
from a sort of an idea,
a preconceived idea,
which often had nothing to do
with anyone having seen it.
But because you could assume
there was those sort of things
that we knew and saw,
whether you saw,
the sort of titillating, you
know, and the candid language,
the salty dialogue,
and the costumes and the shoes.
But, in fact, I feel like the
show always offered up
actual profundity,
and the writing was really smart
and moving and clever
and, I think,
beautifully illustrated
an attempt at finding love,
finding home, you know?
So I am so thrilled
to hear you --
-Also, I just didn't --
I think the part
that I'm really drawn to --
And we're in Season 6.
You're with Berger.
I hope it doesn't work out.
-Yeah.
-But, you know,
I thought the show
would have more of a bow on it,
if that makes sense.
The characters
are so human and messy
in a way that really resonates,
and especially,
like, where it starts.
I mean, that's the part about it
that I did not realize,
because there
are certain shows you watch,
and, you know, you can tune in
to a "Seinfeld" any season,
and there are
the same four characters.
This is a very
different experience.
Like, the arc of it
is really an accomplishment.
And I'm now to the point --
'Cause when we started,
my wife said it's, you know,
whatever, however many episodes,
and I was like, "Oh, boy.
Here we go."
-Yeah.
-"This seems like it's
going to be a lot of TV."
And now I'm like,
"We only have 17 left!"
-Aww. That's so lovely.
-So thank you for that.